and rebel lots of us ready to make it
big in hollywood have come through
the australian city yeah the soaps like
home and away neighbours
uh not me did you audition for them or
anything
i didn't even get a chance to audition
my very first agent meeting
i got rejected because they like looked
at me up and down and said
yeah you're not ever going to be on home
in a way so we're not going to take you
um is that the only job in australia
but now you tweeted this picture
recently of yourself when you were
starting out is this like
a headshot you would do for auditions
first acting headshot
um now there are a lot of questions
thank you yeah okay why am i holding
a softball mitt and a softball just in
case you didn't get
that i was sporty yeah
you can play athletes is that what you
were saying yeah i guess
yeah and then i'm wearing like the
world's finest gold chain
[Applause]
because you're feminine as well yeah
yeah and an oversized t-shirt i've just
let my hair go feral
yeah obviously had not
met up with a professional stylist at
that point in my career
um and then i just like like the random
graffiti because i didn't come from like
kind of the ghetto
area of sydney so most people just have
like a plain background
yeah yeah she's a robin yeah she's a
rebel like yeah but no wonder
nobody thought i would be a professional
actress
that headshot like you can't you can't
stage something
no you look like you were in a great
mood and then you saw something truly
awful
yeah there you go that's it that's it
[Music]
yes